das wird ihr größtes Ding ich glaube
noch nie hat ein Youtuber in Deutschland
ein Video mit so einem wahnsinnigen
Aufwand gemacht 15 Mann stark ist das
Team hier im bonnpützchener rehzentrum
also in bonnpützchen gibt's dieses
rehzentrum wo schon Tanja sfchenko und
Udo Jürgens zu Gast waren und hier
drehen TC og und Phil die ersten Szenen
für ihr neues Video und warum sie so ein
wahnsinnigen Aufwand treiben und welche
welcher sensationelle Hintergrund sich
mit ihrem neuen Video verbindet das
werde ich sie auf KCK so befragen und
natürlich seid ihr wieder dran Liebe
Youtube Community White tity ist auf dem
Weg zurück zu YouTube und unser großes
comebackpjekt steht in den Startlöchern
wird bald auf Youtube geupoadet und
deswegen stellen wir euch wieder Frage
und Antwort genau bei klickum wichtig
wieder wie immer natürlich schaut in den
Infotext da stehen natürlich alle Infos
wenn ihr unbedingt drankommen wollt dann
stellt lieber eine Videoantwort da ist
die Chance besser und natürlich so
kreativ wie möglich ist ganz wichtig
weil so plumpe Fragen ja ich weiß nicht
ob die drankomen und seid bitte fair
stellt vielleicht auch nur eine Frage
dass dann jeder auch drank kommt das wä
super wir freuen uns auf das Interview
ja bis dahin
ciao